broussailles et dernier entraînement
avant les côtes raides de paris donc de
saint quentin jusqu'au premier étage de
la tour eiffel pour 80 km l'objectif le
seul c'est déjà de le finir
[Musique]
hâte hâte
de commencer d'être sur le parcours s'il
ya quand même quelques mois de
préparation donc de le vivre et on a le
beau temps avec nous donc c'est chouette
on a des bonnes conditions
à moins d'une heure du départ je dirais
que mon premier ressenti hier en tout
c'est un peu de stress
mais pas non plus tellement à ce que
pour moi l'objectif est notamment de le
finir un peu de stress 1 c'est sûr c'est
quand même une grosse découverte pour
nous comment on a été fortement
influencée par le grand frère après
après un trek de 60 bornes il nous a dit
je m'inscris sur 1,80 on s'est invitée
avec antoine on a fait un semis donc ça
que ça sert il ya quand même un bon
stress quoi et j'espère vraiment qu'on
va arriver à la tour eiffel soit
on va courir voilà entre entre 7 et 10
heures pouvoir puissance et rien pas
c'est dingue quoi on va courir un petit
peu aussi pour pour soutenir si on va
penser en tout cas au petit aiden qui a
qu'à 22 mois qui a atteint d'un cancer
du cerveau et du coup ces voix là bas on
va courir entre autres pour ça et aussi
guillaume qui courent contre
l'endométriose toujours pour essayer
d'en apprendre toujours plus contre
cette maladie
d'après les experts il faut s'économiser
sur sur les montées en attaque on est
bientôt au 10e km et projet reprendre
mon petit allure un peu plus vite et
puis
voilà
to
[Applaudissements]
you
km 58 hier 52 voilà c'est c'est dur je
découvre des muscles
la tour eiffel
[Musique]
oh